[Musique]
ces chiffres là ils nous viennent d'une
étude menée par les universités de
sherbrooke est une méga le professeur
christian rochefort un ancien cadre du
réseau de la santé a analysé de 2010 à
2016 plus de 6 millions de cas de
travail des infirmières qui s'occupaient
au total 225 mille patients tout ça pour
dire que c'est de loin la plus
importante étude du genre au pays
étude montre qu'une augmentation mais
marginal des heures supplémentaires des
infirmières augmente le risque de
mortalité chez le patient mailhiot plus
en médecine chirurgie par exemple si on
dépasse le ratio d'une infirmière pour
cinq patients eh bien on augmente de 2,5
pour cent le risque de mortalité chez le
malade au québec
dans ce domaine les infirmières ont bien
souvent plus de cinq patients à gérer à
la fois
savez-vous depuis 2004 il viole loi en
californie qui impose en médecine
chirurgie par exemple ce ratio deux
infirmières pour cinq patients au départ
la loi visait à améliorer les soins mais
une étude américaine démontre que
d'autres aspects très positifs à ce
genre de ratios par exemple le nombre de
blessures ou de congés de maladie chez
les infirmières californienne a chuté
d'au moins 30%
bref moins d'infirmières à remplacer ça
signifie des économies bien réel pour un
réseau de santé
[Musique]